Her low freak bitches,
you should step back.
And this is a narrative that gets repeated over and over again in a social
justice warrior culture.
This idea that you should just step back and let these others talk because they
understand as long.
Yeah.
And the others are always other group members.
Right.
And somehow their,
their discourses to be privileged in reverse because hypothetically they're a
member of an oppressed class.
Right.
Of course.
And you can multiply the numbers of oppressed classes ad Nauseum,
which is another part of the problem.
Yeah.
I like the idea is that in giving them privilege because they have been
marginalized,
you will balance things out and you will somehow another reverse the scale.
Yeah.
And that's another example of the class based guilt idea.
You know,
it's um,
it doesn't seem to me self evident that I'm to blame for slavery for example.
I mean,
being a Canadian,
it's a slightly different situation I suppose,
but the,
the idea that as the member,
as a member of a culture,
that you're somehow responsible for the past,
uh,
sins of that culture,
let's say it,
it,
it's a very,
very anti western ethos.
It,
it goes along with this idea of class guilt because your group membership is the
most important thing.
If your group,
at some point in the past,
it's something reprehensible,
which of course every group has done,
that's for sure.
Then you were defacto responsible in the present for that.
How do you think we got to this point where people are repeating these patterns
that were ultimately incredibly unsuccessful and dangerous and deadly in the
past?
Like Marxism for example,
like people proudly proclaim themselves as having Marxist ideology,
one in five,
one in five social scientists claims to be a Marxist kind of thing.
I understand the history.
Why don't you fill people in on how that went bad?
Well,
the estimates vary,
but in the Soviet Union between 1919 to 1959,
somewhere between 30 and 50 million people were killed in internal oppression
alone.
So that's pretty bad.
And then,
and,
and in China,
uh,
which,
which was operating under exactly the same principles,
it might've been up to a hundred million killed during Mao's time.
And of course my was still revered in China,
appallingly enough.
Um,
and Vietnam,
Vietnam and Cambodia.
And wherever these ideas were implemented,
Cuba,
wherever these ideas were implemented,
uh,
the result was absolute mayhem,
absolute mayhem.
And I think what happened is that the Marxist ideas are actually quite
attractive if you're an Intel lectural and if you're,
I would say if you're tilted towards compassion from a personality perspective,
because they're based on doctrines like from,
from each,
according to his ability to each according to his need and the idea that you
should fulfill people's needs or that society should fulfill people's needs is
on the surface of it.
And attractive idea.
Of course,
the problem is who gets to define the needs and who gets to define the
abilities.
And that really is a big problem and well,
and then those ideas were put into practice,
uh,
first in the Soviet Union and Alexander Solzhenitsyn who wrote the Gulag
archipelago did a very lovely job of detailing in,
in horrifying detail how those initial doctrines were transformed into
legislation and then how those legislation was transformed into endless genocide
essentially and almost destroyed the world.
Let's not forget that,
um,
partly with w partly with the help of Castro who just died.
Um,
the,
the doctrines when,
when put into practice in,
into,
into actual practice,
we're were murderous instantaneously now.
But what happened?
They're always apologists for the left in the West,
especially in France,
especially among the French intellectuals,
especially in the late 1960s and then when,
when all of the information about what was happening in,
in the Soviet Union came flooding forward and that culminated say in 19 boat,
1973 it wouldn't,
Solzhenitsyn's book was published.
The French intellectuals changed their tune instead of agitating on a part of
the working class,
which was,
which allied them with a murderous marks is to stay switched and started to talk
about power.
And to talk about group identity,
it was like a sleight of hand.
The underlying pathological philosophy remained exactly the same,
but the surface nomenclature changed and that became very attractive.
And at the same time the Soviet Union dissolved.
And so one of the problems I think we have now a perverse problem is that these
Marxist ideas are very attractive to compassionate intellectuals.
And we don't have good,
bad examples like the Soviet Union around that everybody can point to and go,
yeah,
well that sounds good.
But you know,
what about the murderous death camps in the millions of people who are
suffering,
we still have North Korea,
but you know,
people treat North Korea like it's a joke instead of like it's an exemplar of a
pathological system and people have no historical memory like my students.
And that's partly because they're taught so badly in schools is they have no
idea what happened in the Soviet Union.
They have absolutely no idea.
They know a little bit about the Second World War maybe.
And of course people generally know about the Holocaust,
but they have no idea what happened in the Soviet Union.
So they have no idea where these ideas could lead.
And this and the universities and the high schools are so full of people who are
radically left leaning that they're never taught any,
that students are never taught any proper history.
You know,
they're taught about the evils of capitalism.
And you know,
I mean,
it's not like,
it's not like any system is perfect,
but there's difference between imperfect and,
and consciously murderous.
I think one of the things he use just said that's very important is that it's
attractive to compassionate intellectuals.
People that without really looking at what the potential for these,
the,
these laws and regulations with a negative potential for them is the,
the underlying inclination to lean towards that is that you,
you,
you care about people and then you,
you want people to be okay.
And you know,
when you're kind of treating them like they're your children.
Yes.
And,
and I don't mean that in an entirely sarcastic manner.
Um,
it's reasonable in some sense to treat other people like people that you love,
although it's not reasonable and in very many other ways,
which is why you don't invite every stranger on the street to come and live with
you in your house.
I mean,
everybody puts up boundaries and you have to do that,
but,
and people tend more than,
than we ever expected.
And I've done a lot of research and this in my lab,
but people do tend to vote and think their temperament a lot more than,
than anyone really realizes.
And,
and if you're kind and that's your highest virtue,
then you tend to treat people like they're kin because that's what kind means,
right?
It's,
it's an extension of the word kin.
But that doesn't work well in larger groups.
You need other principals.
And so you look at something like the idea of,
of equity,
which is equality of outcome rather than equality of opportunity.
On the surface of it,
it seems perfectly reasonable to say,
well,
if every resource isn't distributed absolutely equally to every group,
then the system is unfair.
And on the face of it,
that's a reasonable proposition,
but it falls apart under minimal examination.
So here's something to think about for,
for all,
for everyone who thinks that equality of outcome is a good idea,
it's like,
why the hell are you striving for anything then?
Because the reason anyone's strives to better themselves or to develop a skill
or to move forward in life at all is to produce inequality.
You're trying to rise above the mediocre masses every time you make an effort at
anything.
And so everything that we associate,
um,
positive movement forward to a positive motivation is actually an attempt to
render the world more unequal.
Now you're rendering and,
and we equal in adjust way,
right?
Because we might say,
well,
if you work really hard,
you deserve an unequal outcome.
Well,
yeah,
unless you want people to stop working hard.
And that was the old joke in the Soviet Union.
You know,
they pretend to pay us,
we pretend to work.
So it's so,
it's,
it's so thoughtless that that's,
that's the problem.
Well.
And it's also extremely annoying for people who've worked really hard and and
who've made the requisite sacrifices to become successful along some dimension,
to have that immediately attributed to their oppression.
And it's not,
it's not obvious that that's something we want to do.
It's like for the social justice warrior types out there who might be listening,
it's like,
do you,
are you really willing to say that every single person who's accomplished
something as done that as a consequence of oppression,
that that's again with the Soviets claimed with regards to the,
to the successful peasants in the 19 in the just before the 1920s it's like,
well the peasants were in demand dissipated.
They were serfs until about 30 years before that they were served.
They were basically slaves and some of them had clambered up to the point where
maybe they own their hot and a cow could you don't employ somewhat.
While the Soviet claim was,
well that's all theft.
You've got that all cause you're an oppressor.
And so then the Soviet intellectuals went into the villages and just imagine how
this happened.
So imagine a village,
a small town where everyone knows everybody and there's maybe 10 20 people there
who were moderately successful.
Okay.
And so you can imagine that those 20 people have like a hundred enemies at the
bottom of the socioeconomic distribution,
useless,
horrible people who are jealous and resentful about the fact that these people
have been successful.
Okay?
So now the intellectuals come in and say property is theft,
success is oppression.
And then they looked for the people in the village who are willing to move
against those 20 successful people.
Well,
those guys at the bottom,
those hundred resentful,
jealous,
murderous people at the bottom,
they're just waiting for an opportunity to go kick down some doors.
And that's exactly what they did in the 1920s and as I said,
they wiped out all their productive peasants and then 6 million Ukrainian starve
to death if they had posters.
The Soviets produced posters in the 1930s that said,
essentially,
um,
don't forget,
it's wrong to eat your children.
So whoa.
Yeah,
whoa.
There's nothing about the Soviet,
there's nothing that you can imagine that's horrible enough so that it matched
the reality of what happened in the Soviet Union between 1919 to 1959 and you
know,
the West knew about this too early.
Malcolm Muggeridge in the 30s was documenting for,
for England,
for,
for English newspapers.
Exactly what was going on in the Soviet Union.
Bloody intellectuals didn't admit it until the mid seventies you know,
with the exception of people like George Orwell
[inaudible].